welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce dr.
Samir Shah dr. Shah is an MD PhD an
associate professor of Neurosurgery vice
chair of clinical research and director
of psychiatric nurse surgery in the
department of neurosurgery at Baylor
College of Medicine he will be
presenting in our brain initiatives
scientific updates track on mechanisms
of rapid flexible cognitive control in
human prefrontal cortex for complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen my name is dr. Veronica Shannon
and I will be a moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth we also would like to extend
our special thanks to the program
directors of the brain initiative and in
particular dr. James Matt for all their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we therefore encourage you to
participate by submitting questions
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box we will
also offer a unique opportunity to
directly address awardees of the
research on humans division of the brain
initiative the slide panel Q&A will take
place following this presentation today
at 9 p.m. at 9 a.m. Pacific time and
12:00 p.m. Eastern Time
any questions that we don't have time to
address to our speaker will be answered
by an email following the presentation
dr. chefs presentation is educational
and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain rights now without any
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Samir Shah okay well thank you very
much for this opportunity I want to
thank Jim NAT from NIH brain initiative
ROH as well as roham unit lab roots for
giving the opportunity to this talk as
well as the rest of team brain ROH
in general so my talk is a mechanic
mechanisms of rapid flexible cognitive
control and human prefrontal cortex and
this is a Uwe one grant through the
brain initiative Roh project and you
know as is exemplified by our wage in
general the idea here is really to use
the opportunities we have in clinical
nursery for example to directly record
from the brain and ask some really
interesting questions about some of the
very complex functions that our brains
perform so to start off with I want to
course start with my thanks and the the
teams are shown here that are part of
this project so the bailer team is
myself and my two collaborators in the
DBS program here iseman Whisperer Nathan
and Juliet men - I had at the other
clinical site where the data recorded
our Columbia University shown on the
side here with Norman Angus comic-con
and Charlie Schroeder and the
engineering group there you know
including Ollie and Jennifer Gallinas
are also very critical for the reporting
approaches that I'll talk about and I'll
name as we go
also collaborators at the University of
Houston Darien Shea and at google
deepmind for all the deep analytics matt
Bhavana can check in seven at Cornell
set so as I said the are weights in
general has given us the ability and
really encouraged us to examine some of
the very amazing things that our brains
are able to do and one of these very
interesting complex abilities is the
subject of this particular project that
we're going to be doing over the next
couple years and the general idea is
that you know in our in our daily lives
we often find ourselves in situations
that we've never previously faced and
yet we have to be able to respond to
them appropriately meet the unique
demands that they are exacting on us and
respond appropriately and correctly on
the first tribe you don't get to kind of
rehearse this and try it over and over
again oftentimes there's simple examples
of this like you know this traffic on
your way home and you have to take a
different route that you haven't tried
before but then they're also much more
complex and sometimes
very demanding situations of again
actually use either instructions or
previous experience to do the right
thing on the first try our brains have
developed this ability to rapidly
assemble structured contingent programs
of behavior and I'll define that term
program a little bit and to do so in an
immediate ad hoc fashion kind of
dynamically and online and so the goal
of this project really is to understand
the neuro physiological and
computational basis of this veridia
means capacity that we have called ad
hoc self program so that's kind of the
the really the goal of this project so
what do I mean by this ad hoc self
programming I'll give you an example so
if I asked you to raise your hand every
time I said the word minion you know
you've never done this before but you
could probably do it correctly your
first try because you can make the
appropriate associations you know how to
recognize the word minion you know how
to raise your hand you know how to
connect those two things with the
if-then kind of statement and so you can
do this right away and we've never done
it before
through the instructions and through the
tools that you already have accumulated
a more complicated example is if you
were to get on a flight and land at
Heathrow Airport and rent a car and
decided to drive to see Big Ben you know
you've never done this before you've
never driven in London of the UK you've
never rented this particular model of
car before used this particular he or
she have to assembly never turned the
steering wheel on this side of the car
and you know on the left side of the
road but chances are you can
successfully do that again using past
experience and cobbling together the the
the stimulus response relationships that
you already know of from driving on the
other side of the road and be able to
navigate this successfully without
getting into a wreck and having to try
this other times in order to get it
right and you could also you know take
in inputs you haven't taken in before
example complicated road signs and
understand them and interpret them and
execute them correctly so this ability
is really one that maybe not to be too
controversial maybe we're not unique as
a species in doing this there may be
some other non
and primate species that do this to some
degree but I think it's incontrovertible
that we as humans really do this all the
time very well and it's kind of part of
our daily life navigation to be able to
do this successfully so if we break this
down a bit the mental plan perhaps for
for navigating these novel situations
kinship contains three features one is a
concatenation of elementary stimulus
response II units so for example we hear
a particular word you do a particular
action meaning in equals a raised hand
you then string them together the
branching logic such as you know if a
then B but if not seen in D and we also
use prior knowledge or instruction for
example we know what a clutch is we know
an accelerator brake R and we can map
that on to a new situation to do it
correctly so these are these are ad hoc
cell programs in the sense that they can
be cobbled together intuitively rapidly
for our momentary purpose at that time
and then subsequently discard it if we
don't need them again and then a new one
can be assembled in the same manner and
this really allows us to respond and
actively to a large set of circumstances
that we face in our lives on day to day
basis and this really is a type of
learning or type of planning that is in
contrast to trial and error learning in
which case there are programs of action
that are there incrementally sculpted
and we use feedback to guide our future
deviations for previous responses so
this is really not the way that we can
do something like driving in London on a
trial and error kind of behavior so
these these are inappropriate and unsafe
in situations that we frequently face
there are perhaps many parts of the
brain that are involved in this task and
this ability of the prefrontal cortex
especially the dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex is one that is likely heavily
involved in all of some examples of why
this is the case so this is the this is
the area of focus of this project so the
deal with PFC does a lot of important
things that probably related to this
type of
so a few examples of these old study
illusion studies this is this one is
from half a half a century ago 1960s
have shown that lesions in the DLP FC in
humans produce this specific deficit and
the ability to execute a task from
instructions even though we can
comprehend the task and you can even
remember and recite the the task rules
so it's one example of many different
lesion studies in the highlighted
portion of the abstract there shows that
again in this study of several patients
with naturally occurring lesions only
the frontal lobe and the prefrontal
regions affected the ability to follow
test instructions so memory was not a
problem but following the instructional
set was really the deficit from this
part of the brain being lesion also a
bunch of functional studies fMRI and EEG
studies have shown that activation of
this area occurs during execution of
novel tasks this is just one of many
examples with an fMRI analysis on the
left and energy on the right the infra
marshals that novel tasks activate the
state of the brain more than other parts
of the brain and more than tasks that
are practiced and rehearsed the imaging
studying the right again shows that
through Granger causality analysis that
the DL PFC really does you know Lior
cause activity to follow a certain
pattern between the LPC and other brain
regions and it really does originate
from this part of the brain and this is
again in contrast to other studies in
non-human subjects where most of them
are rehearsed and planned and over
trained and presumably different areas
of brain are being activated in
different ways but this is the case as
opposed to the zero Shawn learning of
the self program we're talking about the
study and so finally some work that
we've done ourselves has also shown that
this part of the brain the DL PFC and
it's neural activity really instantiates
the computations underlying encoding of
rules so this was a study done in human
patients undergoing deep brain
stimulation surgery where we recorded
from a single neurons than do PFC in a
simple task where they saw pictures with
tools like
hammer and a wrench and objects that a
tool would act on like a nail or a nice
and they had to intuitively figure out
the rule of task because the the showing
two pictures and had to figure out
whether the two items were similar
pictures of the same item and two
wrenches or whether they had a different
relationship where there was a tool that
could act on object like a branch on a
nut or a hammer on a nail and so they
weren't told which rule to use but they
had to intuitively figure out which rule
to use and then decide whether there was
a match or non match interesting ly
these dlpr signals didn't care so much
about match versus non match but really
were activated when the subject types
who figure out which which which rule to
implement the the act on rule or the is
it similar role so a lot of lines of
evidence suggesting that this part of
the brain is probably involved in the
type of ad hoc self programming that
were interested in so now we can also
use new opportunities for large-scale
neural recordings to really dive into
the wealth and richness of the data that
are dlpr see likely houses so this is an
opportunity afforded by new recording
capabilities that have been developed by
a dealing portabella who's an engineer
at columbia university now this is work
that he did when he was at NYU
along with Jennifer girliness who was
also at NYU and is now currently also at
Columbia so this is a recording array
they called the neural array this is
published a few years ago in Nature
Neuroscience it's an organic material
based array it's all for the thin film
so thickness is on the order of four
microns so things like a thin piece of
cellophane basically it's conformal it
sit on the peel surface and just conform
to all the valleys and grooves of the
peel surface or the sell side and it's
non-penetrating as opposed to you for
example a Utah array which may allow you
to record from several neurons
simultaneously but as a penetrating
array it has those drawbacks
so shown in the figure here is some work
they did initially in animals of mice
using this array and showing that they
can record a single units he went
through this non pennant
a surface didn't film based approach we
see the spikes in the lower figure this
has also been done in humans to a
certain degree that through work that
they had done and this is what we're
going to be incorporating at this
project so to do so we'll be recording
from the human DFC and we're using the
opportunity from very standard deep
brain stimulation procedures for tremor
or Parkinson's etc so for these
procedures the the oor turns into a
laboratory shown here this is a patient
undergoing a DBS procedure we set up a
screen in front of them they have a
button box or joystick near their hand
and this is the recording device that
you see here this is the the surgeons
view of a small incision the small burr
hole and the whole procedure happens
through this opening and so this gives
us a literally a small window on the
brain from which we can record now we've
shown previously again in that study I
showed you earlier with the hammers and
nails that it turns out that the
recording sites are the burn holes
through which the surgery occurs for
these DBS procedures it's typically
always over DL PFC or area 9 kind of
spanning even Bank the supernal sulcus
well ahead of the frontal I feel it's
basically an area 9 so the red circles
in that middle finger show the recording
science from this particular study with
CT scan superposed on an MRI showing
that indeed were in area 9 needs to be
carries the report from routinely in
these clinical procedures and then the
raster on the right shows that we can
isolate single neurons now this
particular study was done with clinical
micro electrodes I shown in the left
part of the figure where before we sort
of the guide to to the cannulas through
the cortex we just hovered above the
cortex and allowed the micro electrode
to record from the neurons in the
cortical gray matter this was fine for
that project but it really is slow going
any particular day you may get one or
two or three neurons on a good day and
so it takes a while to accumulate enough
neurons to build a story so what we're
going to be doing as you predicted is
using that neuro grid array
during this DPS procedure in order to
reporter from spores or hopefully
hundreds of neurons from the cortical
surface in DL PFC and this is some
preliminary figures showing that so we
are in being able to do this and Dion
has manufactured a neuro grid array as
shown in the bottom left that is the
correct form factor for recording
through a standard DBS per hole on the
bottom right you see some data where we
have micro epi recorded and even in
penalty of that figure reef we see some
spiking activity and we can do some
simple phase alignment so micro FP and
likely a single unit activity should be
obtainable through this tactical array
the behavioral tasks that were going to
ask the patients to perform as a novel
task that we have developed in
collaboration with group at a deep mind
mat Babinec and Kurtis Nelson so the
idea is that we want to have a task
where these subjects is doing something
different than every trial so they
really are doing a different task so
that there's no possibility of
overtraining or you know found error
type of learning so we designed the task
what we call the Birds game they see a
bird which particular color that's the
four colors that they're shown and
they're given an instruction that tells
them when to push a button basically
that when to take a photograph of the
bird they may have an instruction that
says something like this I press the
button for all Redbirds until you see
two blue birds in a row after we express
only four green birds so as they're
reading they have to understand this
that you code this and understand what
they have to do and then the trial
starts and so see green bird no don't
press it because they're thinking I need
to look for a red bird so they see a red
bird and they say yes I'm gonna press
the button because I'm supposed to press
for red until I see two blue so then I
see one blue all right I'm still in the
same state I was before
- blue okay so after seeing two blue
birds now now I'm in a different state
and a change in my not looking for a
green bird so for red I'm not pushing
for green I am pushing
etc so this is the one example of a
trial and there would be several of
these trials that presented the subject
here's another example press the button
every time you see the sequence blue
then green then red so that's another
type
rule that they would see in them to
execute that trial correctly mm-hm
these these programs can can be
diagrammed in these these states based
models basically where for example that
first rule I showed you is is program
two on this list and the bottom is the
second rule I showed you is the is the
bottom rule of program three so the
three canonical program structures in
which we change all of the the variables
of the different colors that we can
really have unique trials every time but
there is some program structure that we
can look forward in coding in terms of
the neural data so it's a complex task
but while serving the preliminary data
that subjects should be able to perform
it and it'll provide a very rich data
set to do some very interesting
analytics so what all of those analyses
I'll just talk briefly about some
examples of these as you can imagine
that the data will be very rich every
trial will have a whole several
different impacts of interest including
the encoding of the actual verbal rule
that the subject reads at the time of
the reading as well as the execution and
that pattern of activity we expect will
change over the course of the trial
because the the rule that is appropriate
is going to change over the course of
the trial depending upon what they see
and how that will change is over the
course of the instruction so again with
the collaborators at deep myath with
matt and says help we have a plan of how
to tackle this a complex analysis and
we'll start with some simple order
models and progress to more complicated
ones so they the initial ones that we'll
use or seek to seek current neural
network type of framework very typical
sort of approach to these kinds of
problems where you have input data in
this case or the case example shown in
the figure the input data are various
different words so you know how are you
so these these these quanta of
information are being encoded within the
RNN and then through lots of exposure to
learning they can recurrently come up
with an optimized respond
Latimer just showing the yellow boxes
and emitting the appropriate response in
this case I am fine so for the purposes
of this project we're going to use this
framework to study these program
embeddings so they showed you those
three different programs of canonical
program structures for the task so the
inputs to the encoder in the case of our
task would be the word by word
instructions for example of each program
which would be different for every
program and so the RNN would first be
trained on a huge set of programs and
then for each individual program that's
that's executed each instruction where
my word is going to be input the encoder
and then the output would be the
appropriate response which is to press
are not depressed but so this is an
example of a type of analytics that we
can use a more complicated one would be
this one the differentiable neural
computer which is also developed by deep
mind and published commuters ago where
it's essentially an RNN but with the
addition of a memory buffer like like a
ram for computer so it has the
capability Dhahran in terms of having a
training set that it can be optimized on
but also memory structures within which
to manipulate the data so just a little
bit on a little bit on the preliminary
data we have so far there's for epilepsy
patients with intracranial electrodes
that are not the same testbed as the DBS
patients we're talking about for this
project but you know some interesting
data we've collected so far and it gives
us optimism that this kind of approach
will work the behavior shows that
they're indeed able to perform
appropriately and just a very quick
analysis of PRP so that the DL PFC is
from the top left he really does care
about this type of task and each bird by
bird response and then the riot has
shown the very simple support support
vector machine analysis showing that we
can and the decode the information just
from the LFP in this case recorded deal
PFC which again gives us optimism that
this type of approach will work so the
next couple of years we're going to be
executing the rest of the project using
the recording opportunities that
discussed and the analysis that I
discussed so I'm very excited about this
and thanks for the opportunity and again
thanks to NIH and leverage
thank you dr. Scheck for that very
informative presentation as a reminder
our speaker will follow up with a nice
the questions about his presentation by
email coming up next
join us for a unique opportunity to
directly address awardees from the
research on humans division of the brain
initiative we now have our live Q&A
session following looking forward to
seeing you there